غابه كل مظاهر الحمله الدعائيه في
الفضاءات العامه والاماكن المخصصه لتعليق
برامج المترشحين للانتخابات التشريعيه في
دورها الثاني او تكاد هيئه الانتخابات
تقول انها وفرت كل الظروف لوجستيه
والبشريه لانجاح الاستحقاق الانتخابيه اما
منظمات المجتمع المدنيه فتعيب على المسار
بعد التسرع في الاجراءات والاجال واداره
العمليه المشرفه الانتخابات
غير تشيركي لا شك ولا الاحزاب للمجتمع
المدني الانتخابات
هم اكثر من 700 منهم 455
45 سنه سامحوني ملاحقه
ومع اقتراب يوم الاقتراع بقي الشارع
منشغلا بظروف البلاد الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه واختلفت الاراء فيه حول اهميه
الانتخابات التشريعيه في وقت يؤكد
المتابعون اهميه تركيز البرلمان الجديد في
القطع مع المنظومه القديمه
والجوج الجديده
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس